Here's our food router, and
here's the call to start
monitoring the app's history.
Inside food router is
the list of routes and
the functions to call when
those routes are visited.
When the URL changes to /clear,
call the clear function.
Let's add a breakpoint where we
create the new foodRouter router,
then refresh the page, which will
pause right at the breakpoint.
Let's step through how
everything gets set up.
This calls the parent Router class,
sets up some options,
and then binds the routes.
_bindRoutes is the important
function in all of this.
It gets the route from the foodRouter
router and starts cycling through them.
It takes the last route, passes it and
its callback to the route function.
The route function takes the route and
converts it into a regular expression.
This regular expression will be used
later when matching the browser's URL.
If the callback is a string and
not a function itself, it gets
the function from the foodRouter object.
It then calls Backbone.history.route,
passing it the route and
a callback function.
This function will be called later, but
see here that our original callback
function will be executed
when this function gets run.
Backbone.history.route adds
the route and
the callback to its list of handlers.
Then we just work our way back to bind
routes, and do all that again for
the next route.